hey guys I'm Ryan writes I don't have to
be crazy so we just did a whole video
about out man TV spot number one had a
great great discussion about it was I
think one of the best discussions and we
had some very funny bits too and I
forgot to hit the record button so I am
so sorry guys but tell you what we'll
watch the trailer again and I know this
pisses off people sometimes so we're
gonna really try to recreate our
reaction for you guys okay
it'll be spot on it'll be spot on you're
gonna be like wow Alyssa Ryan amazing
actors yeah so we're gonna we're gonna
recapture the reaction right now a
soldier of the size of an insect
the ultimate see you're different you're
agile fast they need you to be the
ant-man make sense
she's hot Oh Oh me miss that bullet you
tried to hide your suit for me no it's
gonna blow up in your face oh he's a bad
guy
ya know I'm feeling the fun yeah I feel
fairly big and they get smaller and
scared all right I wonder how many
people unsubscribe from that but anyway
let's continue serious discussion let's
try to cover what we cover before I love
the humor of this trailer yes you know
like the last couple trailers were very
kind of serious for the most part I like
the fact that they're like no this is
gonna be a fun action adventure yeah
like and it's a cool to see an origin
tale of ant-man where it's another movie
where he's figuring out this suit we
haven't got her in a Marvel film like
that in awhile like last one we got was
Iron Man as far as like super like
superhero movies go they for the most
part have been heavy on action late on
humor okay or soon they get darker yeah
yeah they've been very dark but you know
with guardians of the galaxy like you
know Chris Pratt adds a certain element
of fun and I feel like Paul Rudd will
add a certain element of fun and like I
also said it earlier Paul read he can
bring to the table what a lot of people
can't he can just naturally without
trying bring a really amazing level of
snarkiness yeah yeah and that adds such
an awesome humor element to it and I
feel like it's gonna be heavy on fun
heavy on action heavy on comedy and it's
gonna be perfect yeah I agree I think
it's gonna be a great fun Marvel movie
and I'm interested in seeing Paul Rudd
really channel a character that's what
I'm hoping for
yeah because Paul Rudd is someone who we
just see normally be the Paul Rudd we
want him to be most of the time he's
shown that he can do characters but in
funny movies you know life how he plays
Brian Fantana an anchorman how he plays
the the surfer stoner and forgetting
sarah marshall like you can you can see
him [ __ ] around with roles and he could
be pretty funny I loved him and I Love
You Man he was he was a total character
that he is that he can be like almost
near character actor but he doesn't
fry like it seems so flawless yeah he's
very sincere yeah I'm interested in
seeing this because when someone does a
Marvel character their identity becomes
known as that character for quite a
while oh yeah yeah sure like if you
don't know Chris Hemsworth you know Thor
if you say Chris Evans and there was
like who's that he's Captain America
people are gonna know so I think that's
what's gonna happen with Paul Rudd if he
nails down a character and we're not
focused and thinking about Paul Rudd but
we're actually just buying the character
right because you know I feel like with
a lot of character actors or you know
serious actors that have been in a lot
of stuff up until you know their
breaking point a lot of people might
know them but they might not necessarily
be a household name
up until that particular character and I
feel like this is gonna be that
character for him we captured everything
we said when we thought we were
recording the first time right we did I
think we did I think all right guys if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects so you
could check out Alyssa's channel Elissa
be crazy all someone has a gaming
channel they let's say be gaming and you
can follow us on Facebook Instagram and
Twitter where if we get enough followers
we can get product placement for things
such as subway subway is delicious there
are nutritious they taste good eight yo
I'm doing a subway commercial right now
what the [ __ ] are you doing you don't
just throw in Starbuck hey okay stop you
know what now I can't even promoters
[ __ ] up the girl [ __ ] up the bit
like I care I'm sorry sometimes I'm too
mean to you when the cameras rolling
it's true he's never this mean to me
outside of this there's an image I got
to maintain subway